on the topic generally about repentance
and supplication.
There's such a small difference between
the two, but it's a world in itself. But
Dr. Zakia, if I could just pose the
first question today, why is Ramadan
referred to often by many people as
being the month of supplications?
Alhamdulillah.
Before I answer a question, I would like
to first define what is the meaning of
the word supplication. Supplication
means to call upon Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala the almighty and glorious with
devotion with sincerity and solemnity
and with complete submission
and a beloved prophet wasallam said it's
mentioned in say had ofdi had number
2616 a beloved prophet wasallam said
that there are three gates of goodness
the first is
fasting which is a shield from the
hellfire.
Second is a satka that is charity that
charity extinguishes sin same as water
extinguishes fire and the third is
standing in prayer in the late hours in
the night.
So here we realize there is a
relationship between supplication,
prayer and fasting. And Allahh says in
the Quran in surah Bakar chapter number
two verse number 186
Allah says that if my servants ask thee
concerning me tell them I am indeed
close to them and I listen to the prayer
of every supplicant and tell them that
if they listen to my call
willingly and if they believe in me I
will take them to the straight path.
Here we realize the closeness of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala along with his
believers his servants and slaves and he
says if my slaves if my servants my
servants means the closeness that the
human beings have with Allah subhana wa
t'ala if they ask me concerning me tell
them I am indeed close to them it shows
the closeness between the believers and
Allah subhana wa t'ala and he says I
will respond to them
and Allah further says in the Quran in
surah Isa Chapter number four verse
number 32 but ask from the bounty of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala and a beloved
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
it's mentioned in say bkari
volume number eight had number 6502
the beloved prophet said that Allah says
ask me and I will give it to you ask me
your protection and I will protect you
and as far as Ramadan being called as
the month of supplication
A beloved prophet said it's mentioned in
a say had of al- bahhaki had number 6393
where the beloved prophet said that
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala does not
reject the prayer of three kinds of
people. One is the father who prays for
his child his son or daughter. The
second is a fasting person especially
when he breaks his fast. And the third
is the traveler.
And a beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he further said it's mentioned
in say hadith of ibn maja had number
the prophet said that Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala emancipates
the slaves from the hellfire
during every hour when the fast is
broken and he does this every night and
our beloved prophet also said it's
mentioned say hadith of say
had number 988 it Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala ransoms the Muslims from the
hellfire every day and night in the
month of Ramadan and he answers the
prayer of every Muslim every day and
night in the month of Ramadan. So
because Allah subhanana wa ta'ala he
listens to the supplication of the
person who fasts and he gives a special
status that's the reason Ramadan is
called as the month of supplication.